Speaker 1: Florida Republican Governor Ron
DeSantis had both endorses lose on Tuesday and
of course, the failed former and wannabe future
president Donald Trump is trying to capitalize
on this. The truth is, Trump's trolling thing
aside, the truth is that Ron DeSantis is not only
increasingly low in the polling, he is also
visibly losing, notably losing political capital
as two endorses have lost. Let's look at exactly
what happened. The Hill reporting. DeSantis sees
both endorsed candidates lose. DeSantis stepped
into the Kentucky Republican gubernatorial primary
to back former U.N. Ambassador Kelly Craft,
endorsing Craft on Election Day. A little bit
late in the game as polling in the run up to
the election projected craft lost to Attorney
General Daniel Cameron. Trump backed Cameron.
Whatever you believe about Trump's endorsement
record and it's quite mediocre overall,
this is very clearly a public win for Trump.
The other example, of course, is what was the
other example? I actually don't have it here.
Who else did did say, I don't know. Oh, Oh, I
see here. Democrats Flip Flop Mayor's Office.
Republican Daniel Davis Succeeds Mayor Lenny
Curry. DeSantis backed Davis, but Curry won
there as well. So Trump immediately seizes on
this, as I would be doing as well, because this
just looks very bad for DeSantis. Trump posting
to his platform. Troth Essential quote. Wow. In a
big upset, the sanctimonious backed Republican
candidate for mayor of Jacksonville, Florida,
lost. This is a shocker. If they would have
asked me to capital endorse, he would have
won easily. Too proud to do so. Fools. This is
a big loss for the Republican party. Remember,
Rob only won because of me. He now calls Ron
DeSantis Rob. Then continuing to post truths,
quote, the sanctimonious loss of Jacksonville in
Kentucky last night. Not good. And then lastly,
quote, Congratulations to a, quote, star in
Kentucky, Daniel Cameron, who easily won the
Republican nomination for governor. He had my cap.
But we'll see. Complete and total endorsement.
The sanctimonious backed candidate came in a
distant third. Ron's magic is gone. He also lost,
shockingly, in Jacksonville last night, Mayor. And
the truth is, you know, Trump lies all the time.
But Trump is rightly assessing that.
Desantis's I was going to call it a campaign,
but it's not yet really a campaign. DeSantis would
be campaign is in complete and total freefall. I
reported to you yesterday that DeSantis is
polling had collapsed all the way down to
just over 20% in the Republican primary.
And overnight, DeSantis is now below 20%,
just barely at 19.9. And as I've said
before, with Trump surging now at 56,
remember a few weeks ago, Trump was at 43. If
Trump's at 43, you look at that and you say, hey,
if I just get the non-Trump vote, if Trump has 43,
there's 57 out there available. If I can get that,
I can win the primary without taking a single vote
from Trump. Trump now is all the way up to 56%
when Trump is at 56%. You now have to contend
with the reality that if you scoop up somehow
all of the non-Trump vote, you only have 44%. And
so then you have to justify how can I take votes
from Trump? And I don't know how DeSantis does
it. That's where we are right now. The DeSantis
campaign truly in freefall. That being said,
interestingly, the reports are that DeSantis still
plans to announce a candidacy. And as I've said
before, I can see both sides. On the one hand,
I don't see what the Santos's path to victory is
right now. On the other hand, if you're DeSantis
and you have sycophants around you, as many of
these people often do, you might be saying to
yourself, the fact that I even have 19.9% and I
haven't announced tells me this may be my shot.
Sure, I could wait until 2028 when I guess the
Santos would be 48 years old. I could do that.
But anything could happen between now and then.
Might I? Might be trying with 5% in 2028. I have
20 right now. Maybe Trump gets indicted again or
again or again. Gets arrested a couple more times.
It pulls him off the campaign trail. Anything
could happen. Maybe I need to be there. Sort
of like the Seinfeld episode where I think it
was Jerry who says, listen, I'm just going to
be there for her after some kind of a breakup, and
then I'll just be there. And who knows? If she's
interested, then I'll just be there. This may be,
quite frankly, DeSantis approach. I only have 20%.
I don't know how I'll take supporters from Trump,
but if things go wrong, I will just be there. I
don't think it looks good for DeSantis. Reports
are he may announce within the next 7 to 10 days.
We will watch it. One quick reminder, Monday,
Memorial Day, we are doing a one day membership
special. The goal is to kick start membership and
we will be doing it with an incredible discount
code. If you'd like to be notified of how to
take advantage of this membership special on
Monday morning, Memorial Day. All you have to
do is get on my mailing list at David Packman
dot com. Remember that the David Packman show is
an audience supported program. We do an extra show
every day for our members. It's called The Bonus
Show. You can sign up at join Pacman dot com. You
can also use the coupon code. 24 starts now.
That's the numbers. Two. Four starts now.
All one word, no spaces. Cram it all together.
Lowercase capitalized doesn't really matter.
Join pacman dot com coupon code 24 starts
now. Read about the benefits. Do the thing.